have you sought people like this guy
answer don't decide I've so be psycho
comment on the Gaza Strip I have people
like this guy yes yes you have here's
short innocent people know whether
they'll finish and if it is who goes to
the wonderful so now let me get this
fire this guy is the biggest terrorist
ever
[Music]
but I shall open
lady so high level feed them
what then
[Music]
yes okay okay okay okay
[Music]
you know you know yeah that was it was a
good now now what do we define what we
define as a jihadi okay he said he wants
every div shot dead okay what do you
define as a jihadi what do we define is
definition of the jab that definition
with Sharia a jihadi a boil and jihadi
is different thoughts jihad okay a
volunteer D someone who's going before
the non-believers to create and
establish what the Islamic caliphate
okay none of this is causing trouble is
in trouble I'm sorry brother you're not
helping you're not helping the tool
we're trying to talk here I am good
look at the cab he doesn't like it
because you look like he's using it he's
using this is using this to divert the
topic it okay
yeah what should you have a ball please
because I was gonna talk I'm gonna back
off here I don't know do you explain
it's not a one more time please sure
this is what I need that was channel yes
okay where's a lead oh don't worry
you're gonna find out tonight yeah now
tell me what's the definition of jihadi
as I'm said one minute ago a jihadi work
volunteer art is somebody that fights
the non-believer to establish an Islamic
caliphate in Surrey although that is
Surya okay can you show me any mercy
okay so this guy this guy so this guy I
eat the noisy Jaime finish finish finish
finish the game your game is over this
is is over Scott me watch it
listen different ballgame now yeah okay
this guy he crave this kinda jihadi this
guy these are the people who go to the
frontline of throw stones you know
stones have you guys seen stones before
and most of the mature so to this so to
this terrorist sympathizer and
stabiliser
you've been to that broad I don't
suppose they muster for them I was
laying on the floor there's jihadis
myself
you're a terrorist this innocent boy
listen children you go to Charles system
that's not a child
listen listen listen have you have you
shot people like this guy answer don't
be shy don't be shy comment on the Gaza
Strip I should have people like this guy
yes yes you have he has short innocent
people learn whether they'll finish any
finish who go to the wonderful
[Applause]
this guy is the biggest he's causing
trouble okay Allah says in the Quran
speaks with mothers and sisters
it's I'm here hello we're holding your
mic you hold it this way to speak to me
yeah you might come back to wear your
mic is yeah now Allah says in the Quran
speak the truth even is against yourself
here
therefore we saw somebody causing
trouble he was a Muslim we told him no
he's a troublemaker get to it yeah okay
he was a Muslim yeah I will tell you we
don't care who he is
yeah if he's causing trouble it's
starting with this guy for no reason so
you have to go yeah hopefully is one now
let's reach now now resume mouth you
know now let me see let me see speaker
he's talking about jihad is here and
this guy this guy is the same guy he
goes I shoot these people he shoot
people who come in for stones you are
James you are a terrorist okay
can you support this is what actually
visible yeah killing innocent people and
kids yes you're making that out I make
you know yes you just said to me was a
good you just said to me this guy you
said I shoot people like that in the
heart and in the heavier now he's
regretting it and your camera
[Applause]
to run away from you okay okay listen
listen
you said you should be Hadees yeah to me
to me if we have if we have the power
let me tell you something it the Prophet
peace be upon him spoke harshly against
these Isis come back to the most the
conference said if I lived at their time
I would destroy them life once again
once again the Prophet peace be upon him
said the ISIS Rwanda called hydrogen the
cosmic wisdom said if I lived at their
time I would wipe them off the earth
like God Almighty code is destroyed and
Old Testament nations here perfectly
said I will destroy them why because
they're the biggest enemy to know I was
in this terrorist and we're gonna go to
them yes chaos
[Applause]
are you okay in the Old Testament and
animals there are no justification to do
that oh yeah
you're the biggest terror cell you know
what let me read those verses and when
and like you say these shootings you had
these young little kids in the heart and
in the hair so the kid you never saw a
kid in my life
oh you do not say okay has Israel
yes yes we are
well yeah Aparna ie will you condemn
Hezbollah I condemn anyone that goes in
to see people be it is below Hamas be
Israel be it even if it's the British
government who go and kill innocent
people stated in Arab hundred sent by
you than you would we would it can I say
something
well do you condemn Hezbollah with me
ones that kill innocent people yet not
Hezbollah has more life thank you
innocent know if they do it damn simple
as 100% you know what this guy this guy
you know no you know what's in this this
you don't know suddenly no no something
yet I was making dua to Allah o Allah
please
and one day I walk I was walking
yeah yeah okay let me guess once you're
else Muslim you're an expert on Islam
come on yeah born Christian my son good
thank you because that's so in the first
much member initially i was a 'muslim
before so now you're
I believe I can fly in midseason he's
worth within your community within Islam
know within Muslim Arabs hope yes yeah
yeah there is a combat and I see my
design in the life I've heard I've heard
it it's wrong it's wrong syphilis how do
you combat anti-semitism because all
right I grew up in them over they used
to call me something like I had friends
at home with my head you know what they
used to call me I used to call me the
okay June implying that all the other
things were not okay you need to hold
the state he's gonna complain I'm
looking this way don't wanna just yeah
what what how do you combat
anti-semitism in your community dropping
bars yeah okay you're gonna answer none
what community you know I said I'm not
I'm Turkish okay you do that most that
numbers the Motor City can you tell me
can you tell me what is that song
speakers :
all right guys no no no what coming oh
I'll give you the footage your money no
will annoy him Oh me and Jamie are gonna
give the footage 2011 residents oh I see
I oh I see they were less likely to
justify the targeting and killing of
civilians and residents of non oh I see
states so 18 percent believe Millett
military tax and civilians are justified
in the oh I see no no I sustained 20
complete percent believing that our
audience is justified so what does that
teach you about Muslims and non-muslims
a lot lives and you stop complaining
Horseman's and islam most Muslim
countries are not Islamic
yes it's well the truth is well the
cheaper ones or not we are you guys I
don't know if you look like the left
love to complain it when you talk to
actual Muslims they know there's a
difference because there is a difference
man away way going way way way we
decided the Quran is teaching okay he
wants pace the OIC is Lysanne 55 and
they may say 56 because I count their
faith state Palestine anyways but yeah
that is mainly secular country
definition to high-definition do you
think the country of these Isis scumbags
that run people over the world what do
you fit into the category because we
said anyone that kills innocent people
for political reasons is a terrorist
that's definitional terrorists you
fainted at Isis our internet never ever
ever kill an unarmed did you not decide
to show you something a guy be showing
the place and he said good Carney you
can give it you're looking at the one of
it prove it whatever yeah
telling you I am proud to chew jihadi I
can tell anyone that kills a kid one
time what time zone Israeli military
eyewitness I witnessed one please please
please please speaking Italian what I
wanted to say I was surrounded by jihadi
tired three years that I served in the
idea yeah okay and the IDF had the
strictest rules of engagement in you
clowns have no idea I'm gonna laugh my
hourly finish okay yeah in the what in
the three years that I was there
yeah one time I saw mistreatment of a
prisoner by soldiers who were pissed off
yeah yeah and I stood up and cracked
this [ __ ] Saturday and I do not accept
that because I think targeting anyone
unarmed he's never accepted why didn't
give a [ __ ] what background you come
from
tonu condemned Israel where your narrow
version if you still do that you said
you said to me that I had a gun is one
who got shot yeah why would you really
thinks is your Israel soldiers I'm going
to see a man with a gun and they're
gonna give us energy gas and ice in the
bullet we're talking about they will not
say this in the tear gas you know very
well you may showing that any nightmare
obviously no I haven't loved you can't
use my port there yes no why there is no
way you can someone like that without
them being there they're hot all these
kids you a journalist now we talk about
journalist you join us on happy days man
don't try it
this is the okay okay okay how do you
get fun don't worry Karen first of all
unit on the ex-muslim bar actually I'm
half Armenian half Assyrian okay
innocent people that's there you go
don't kill innocent yeah you do it's
going to Germany abilify your Hitler
while before and it's not being a mom
ask your question if the if the person
was here today
how would he treat you do you think I'll
treat me how do you think he would have
treated I might created the jury's in
okay how how tell me some I am basically
defending now in arming the fat defense
mode right yeah it looks fourteen
hundred years
yeah of being killed by you people all
of you perhaps but yeah hold on hold on
why what do you want to call it right
yeah by your Muslim brother being killed
okay mistake not even in Egypt in
Pakistani everywhere right yeah yeah
yeah I think you're talking you're
talking about one love around the
torture I'm Kelly's from Turkey yeah
this from Turkey
now you're clear this is no Iranian
you're mainly okay okay come let's
maybes respect the ladies over uncle I'm
quiet
Assyrian course father yes Janaki at
work for him shut up uncle uncle
I'll tell my trainer his new any
pressing on them yeah
what is that you're stepping on my
trainer yeah I'm so happy you'll
understand right yeah my mother song
from kill myself Iran all right okay he
said on my own accord
yeah on a Turkish yeah isn't this dreams
great Islam a yeah but you know
auditioning does to say peace be upon
him said the people with who's more
educated you want Abubakar Baghdadi
that's got a PhD in Islam and you can
say oh he's a piece of [ __ ] decent
that he doesn't understand this does
understand all right okay okay one
second one for you one second the
Prophet peace be upon him
all right mom come on yeah yeah
no that's it do you guys want to go do
you be in trouble man trouble you are in
trouble
[Music]
I'm cause my question
ibaka daddy yeah just because he knows
I'll because the question that is asked
is this what about our our teaches that
we look up to for example they might be
noisy with Abu Bakr al-baghdadi so which
one is on the truth I'm a baka baka dawa
teaches just because somebody knows the
stomach knowledge and applies in the
wrong way at 6'5 yeah look I know you
got my shop here okay you got my shop
now you try to divert the topic here
okay you'll recover you become believe
it even though you get this training he
destroys everybody my brain isn't
destroyed
my wife listen the only reason I'm
treating this guy a bit firm yeah it's
because he's somebody he look he the guy
he was showing the face he goes good
shot boy is he okay him for him I'm not
gonna [ __ ] if you see not the best
other look three weeks ago I was
speaking to a Jewish right over here we
had a lovely discussion with the Jewish
guy he told me a few things about his
religion and we get on you are not the
same you are a clicker enemy to us
Amazon Prime and send you over yeah
but now he's using the cigarette for me
to on the but nowhere nowhere I can ask
you a question if the Prophet peace be
upon was here today
how would he treat you because you said
1400 years they smelted you the children
okay here we're probably behead me if
the public peace okay hey yeah one of
these who was Jewish
how did he end up with Jewish wife can
you tell us a man grooming gangs here in
Britain victims was what I like white
girls I'm I'm not a racist
[ __ ] jerk is your time
so what because you might urges do you
say you know if you stop
even Jesus comma saying you know like it
I'm not anymore right yeah just because
I didn't turn my good ha for 1,400 years
here being slapped this way in this way
yeah yeah I'm happy not one friend sky
was listening to me
right as I sell had genocide from two
sides my mother my father side the
second Assyrian genocide is data after
today now to present now even now in
northern Iraq in Syria in Iran in
everywhere nothing to really feel
nothing that they were brought the
Muslim brothers and and what you see one
day are you see any condemnation from
you for me from any of you you're not
subscribe to me then why people being
you don't have no idea about me
yeah
[Applause]
anywhere in the world
yes they are
the lives of the yeah you're right
you're not you can't deny when using
shadow you want to the most of the
motion saved you yeah
this is the guys okay this is the this
is the Treaty of the Prophet peace
people with the people of the book the
lives of the people of Madrid and its
surrounding area their religion their
land their publicly the cattle and those
of them are present or absent their
messengers and their place of worship
are under the protection of Allah and
his guardianship of his prophet their
present States shall never be interfered
with nor their rights meddled with nor
the I Do's be formed no Bishop shall be
removed from his office the intention
being that no change in whatever state
everyone is in shall be made the me
finish is a treaty Orphanage on Venus
neither the people shall be punished for
any past crime of murder in a me finish
here is hurting you nor shall they be
are compared to do the military services
remains a shock neither shall usher or
tech stocks of grain be imposed on them
nor should any one any army into the
area if any of the people of Natron
demands arise Bravo please please allow
me if any of the people of mahjongg
demands arises justice shall be done
between the plaintiff and the respondent
neither oppression shall be allowed to
the perpetrated on them nor should they
be permitted to oppress anyone neither
finish whatever has been written in this
pact Allah and Muhammad Sawa will sell
him his puppet or guarantors for it
unless there is an order from Allah in
this connection and as long as the
people of Nashville remained faithful
and I dare to their conditions which
have been made for them this is the
covenant you will live on the peaceful
now let's look at the people that
migrated
okay yes calm down calm down we're not
we're not between each other
imagine having treat the number is it
nice do you see what's happening guys
[Applause]
yes he was here when I finished it Pat
me on the back here okay I need it for
tomorrow
when I finish this I'm gonna because I
need to pray okay okay all right
this is the Jewish people we lived under
a stomach really stomach state really
she's bye-bye of Eden mi40 doesn't this
is why that's very jury Fatiha
he wrote a letter he says here in the
land of the church we have nothing to
complain of we presents great fortunes
much gold and silver in our hands we are
now pressed with a heavy don't say
whatever you want ok reach all the
fruits of the earth everything is cheap
and every one of us live in peace and
freedom
here the
Jew is not compelled to wear a yellow
hat as a badge of shame as in the case
of Germany where even goodbye
all right any more questions I'm gonna
go play when I come back on the
periphery and myself